elizabeth renzetti of globe and mail.com
wrote an article recently about icky pop
i don't know if the two of you happen to
read it but she basically said
if iggy pop can't live off of his art
then what chance do we all have
and i'm just gonna play the part of
elizabeth for a second so she writes
a new reality has tripped him up and
it's the same one shafting artists all
over the world
namely that everyone wants to listen and
no one wants to pay
so in short the cat is out of the bag
and the new electronic devices which
estranged people from their morals
also make it easier to steal music i.e
content than pay for it
we know this is something that the two
of you have had to deal with
um we wanted to get your thoughts on it
you want me to start
you did start with a hard question yeah
yeah yeah no
yeah go ahead and start so yeah my
feeling is that we're
in a period of transition more than
anything i don't necessarily think that
what is going on right now
is the future i think things are always
changing
and yeah i agree that right now it's
particularly difficult to
monetize your art especially if you're
doing something
if you're trying to do something very
independent and very um
outside of the system um but i don't
necessarily think this you know
that people i i guess i feel like
a monetized uh
is is coming and i think we're we're
slowly going to
enter into a period where you know
artists really find their niche and
figure out how to survive
i don't necessarily i think right now a
lot of people are still
thinking about the heyday of you know
the last 20 years you know where dvds
and ancillary markets were like a big
thing
and um everybody still the industry as a
whole is still kind of clinging to the
money that they were making
on that market but i don't necessarily
think um
and i think it just hurts particularly
hard right now same thing with the music
industry it hurts right now
because we're just going through this
transition but i guess
optimistically i think it's it's going
to kind of work it's work its way out
yeah i think it's two things i think
it's the ease of access and
the whole piracy idea or
movement has happened out of a reaction
to ease of access
and things being really overpriced
um i think that when you know when i was
a teenager i spent all my babysitting
money on
cds that cost 15 18 and i might only
like one song
on the album but then you you just
shelled out 18
and so i think it's a same with the cost
of dvds and blu-rays and
and people just keep trying really hard
to keep locking up territories and
making
region-coded disks and ultraviolet this
and you know this digital rights
management
and the the longer that hollywood and
the record industries
keep trying to push people out and
charge them
a lot the angrier they get and
there's got to be a happy medium at some
point and hopefully there will be
whether it's a bittorrent bundle or that
with a pay gate
or just something that's
eliminates the barrier of access and
also eliminates the
overpriced nature of how things are so
that's that's my hope
is what's happening so this article that
elizabeth bransetti wrote
said that um iggy pop mentioned that if
he had to live off of his royalties
he would have to ten bar between sets
basically
knowing that you're still making films
even if you knew you had to take side
jobs doing commercials
music things like that you assisting him
or you doing your own projects is that
something that you're willing to
succumb to to make something that you're
so passionate that you're willing to
spend so much time on
i mean fortunately for us we've never uh
had the opportunity to
to put golden handcuffs on ourselves we
live
extremely simply and frugally and so
that's never
i think it's much harder for guys to
fall down the money tree than
want to climb up it if that makes sense
like a guy like iggy pop
and you know i don't know him personally
i don't know his lifestyle but i can
only guess
you know came with a nice car and house
and and all of these things and so it's
a lot harder to
adjust to giving that up than it would
be
to adjust to the idea that this may
never be lucrative
on a broader level and um
i i'm always um going to be behind
whatever leaps out of jamin's heart and
mind so
whatever that takes oh thanks um but
it's true and and i guess
um the point is not to make a
our goal i guess has never been to make
money
um and we do have to do all those things
we do take we do take commercial work we
do take side jobs and
i think that's we're terrible bartenders
yes
shaman just got fired from the movie
theater yeah that's right um
but um but i think that's
the fame and and money should not
ultimately be the goal of doing this and
it's really not for us so i think that
that's um
yeah yeah and i think in a way it's kind
of good i mean i think it's
i don't think struggling has ever been a
bad thing for artists
i say that at this moment i will not be
saying that in another moment but uh
but i do think that uh i do think that
that's not necessarily a bad thing i
mean i think that
um i mean there's always struggle in the
in
in this business but i i do think that
um
it does help weed out people who really
their hearts are not in it you know and
i think
you it's just you really shouldn't be
doing this unless you really
are passionate about it and um
you know at that point it isn't about
the money and it's i mean and don't get
me wrong it's really really hard
to survive and that's a really critical
thing and trying to figure out that
balance as we all know
but yeah that's all i got
every movie is going to test someone
once twice
after it's made so on the frame what
were one or two of those moments where
your backs were against the wall and
then you you were definitely
going through with it but it was at a
moment where just
things didn't look good
most moments during the frame i think
we're like that
i think it's funny because every time
you get into
the shooting you know you prepare and
you prepare and you prepare
and then once you're actually in the
shooting process
you just you know once that starts you
can't you know you're at a point
where you can't go back you know and um
i remember there was about
maybe a third to halfway through the
film i just remember saying that i
remember thinking
oh we're already in this we can't we
can't turn around
and we're so exhausted and i think it's
just i think just getting through it
as a whole i mean it's such a monumental
task and you always hear filmmakers say
that
making a movie is like war and it really
is i mean it's i
we always say that if you're having a
really good time making a movie you're
probably not making a very good movie
because it's just too easy um and uh
but that's i mean that's part of it um
and uh so i think just just sustaining
just
staying on your feet the whole time
through and just getting it done
if you can just do that then that's an
amazing accomplishment in and of itself
um but as far as like specific moments
there was a few i guess i think
we had uh so we did about 11 weeks of
filming on the frame it was
55 days and um
there was a period at the very midpoint
of the shoot we had done three weeks of
night shoots and as you'll see if you
watch the movie
there's like tractor trailer tractor
trailer and car
cop or cop car chases not in the budget
but we pulled it off anyway
and um staying up those three weeks and
then having just the stress of having
those
trucks rented and i it really was this
you you look down both sides of the
tunnel and you're right in the middle
and you have to make a decision do we
stop here and start walking backwards or
do we just keep going and the choice was
obviously like we have all these people
and resources and
people around us and you just keep
moving and so
it's just a stand up and what put one
foot in front of the other everyday
type of situation but we made it can you
give
specifics of what may be occurred was it
you know i mean
probably putting a credit card as a
deposit for these trucks and and
you know there's a damage or whatever
you know you're liable so
what was going on just dumb faith
i suppose blind dumb luck faith um
no it was uh she looked like a janitor i
did i had
so many keys i had the keys to three
semi trucks
uh winnebago like four picture cars
it was like that no transpo department
of course and so
had we wrecked any one of those things
our lives would have been over
um so now let alone shut down the
production but
um yeah i mean those are the risks that
you take um
we have a magnet on a refrigerator that
says leap and then that will appear and
that's all you can think in a moment
like that is i've just got to throw
myself
off the roof here and hopefully somebody
catches me when i fall and
it worked out so you just kind of have
i guess just we were really lucky in
that we had a really really good crew
i mean it was the best crew that we've
ever worked with and and that was that
was sort of our net
you know and everybody just
just kind of kept us energized and just
kept going um
even though we you know as every film
that you make you just take on way too
much yourself and you always wish you
had
you you hadn't done that but i mean our
crew was just constantly just kind of
keeping us energized and keeping us
optimistic and i think that's
that's mainly how we got through it yeah
well it's just the uh
the thrill i guess of um having gotten
that far it's already so hard to write a
script
raise money get everybody there that's
the last time to sit down and fail
you know you have to you have to keep
going and there was there was truly
never any option
to quit there really like we that never
that's never crossed our minds ever it's
just if there was a moment that was
kind of that like which direction did we
go a moment it was probably
in the middle of those night shoots
jamin we have a quote
from you that one of our our people dug
up now i'm just kidding
one of our people from an article that
jason heller from westwood
yeah yeah and you say i think the
tendency in filmmaking is to always do
something bigger
our trajectory is to always do something
better
so how is the frame better than ink man
um that's a good question you know i
think with um
with the frame and ink you know i try to
with every film that we make i think the
tendency is to
disparage the last film that you made
and be like oh this sounds so much
better
um i am unquestionably more proud of
this film than i am of
inc though i think it's a more
challenging film for audiences than than
i think inc is
um and i think i think it's just a
combination of a lot of things i think
we've just gotten to be better
filmmakers i think
over the years i've gotten to
at least i like to think i've gotten to
be a better writer um and i think that's
probably one of the most important
things is just
really knowing how to write and that
takes a long time to
it's a tough skill to acquire and um
just over the years i think i've gotten
better at it
the the performances in the frame are
outstanding
um and i think it's just
for me for me personally it's hitting on
a deeper level than you
than even ink was i think ink
strikes a really personal chord as well
but for me the frame
um you know i i guess
how do i put it it's just um it's just
hitting
things that i i've spent a lot of my
life thinking about
and um and i guess i'm just really proud
to
to have put that on screen in a way that
i think is
successful and and it's exactly what
i wanted to be and i think and i think
at the end of the day if you've just put
on screen what you intended to put on
screen then you're succeeding
you know and it's so much less about how
much of the audience likes the film and
more
are you realizing your vision on screen
and to me that's what the frame is
kyla uh all of those things and it's not
a romantic comedy from the
it sounds really funny and fun
it's not great from what he knows so um
i think we just uh you know getting
through ink as you guys know
um i've talked with you about it before
it was really hard
but um and i'm i will always be
extremely proud of that movie and we'll
always love that movie
um but jame and i feel really dug
deep on a writing level and
and we just took no prisoners i feel
like we just dug deeper on every
level that we could production value
ambition and scope of
the the artistic um scope of the movie
um and yeah i'm
i really love it i love both but i i i'm
with jamin i really think
we're we're both just really proud of
the film
either of you perfectionists
he's more of a perfectionist yeah it's
funny
my uh my mom who's here somewhere she uh
she she likes to tell stories when i was
a kid i um
and i was coloring in coloring books i
would just go
crazy not making things perfect in a
coloring book
and that just and i would just get
really upset and that's pretty much
what my life is now with filmmaking i
just i tend to just really obsess
and uh you know and i think there's a
certain i think with any filmmaking you
have to be
willing to just kind of go with the flow
because you just don't have the ability
to make everything perfect but i think
as much as as we can we try to make
everything as
close to our vision as possible and so i
guess that means
i get obsessive compulsive sometimes but
that's
not entirely a bad thing though
sometimes it is he kind of has to though
because
if if the person in charge is not that
way
everybody else's work is not as good if
that makes sense like that
everybody's following that lead and
everybody wants to achieve
what's in jamin's mind and if he's not
really
passionate and certain about his vision
then everything else suffers
so it gets
a little bit tough from time to time
when you get really hung up on
something that maybe is not that
important but i can understand why he
does and and that's also i understand
that's
that's exactly why um he does take
things so seriously and they do
turn out well in my opinion and just
it's it's a ton of
love and care and passion that gets
poured into that it's not just
happenstance and how does your being
pragmatic
balance it out because that sounds like
a great a great team
in once because it was two
perfectionists i think that would be
people fighting over their idea versus
another yeah
yeah i mean i think there's there's such
a huge part of this that's just
getting the job done you know and and i
think that that's
um really where kiowa shines is
just as a as a producer she's just
very good about just i i always say this
about kyla that
which sounds not that glamorous but i
think it's a really really
big credit to her is that she is the
most competent person that i know
and and that's a really big thing just
to be
competent at everything and especially
as a producer and she just can
can get anything done and get it done
efficiently
and which for me is extremely valuable
because it allows me to just focus on
the things that i know are really really
important
and then you know if i know something
requires specific attention then you
know
i'll let her know and she knows what
those things are it's not like i have to
tell you but
um so for me i guess it's hugely
liberating because it allows us
we're not spending a lot of time
meticulously going
through things that don't matter um for
the most part
every now and then i got hung up on
something but um
but it's just that the work you know
generally gets done and then when
then we really need to focus on
something we do would you say that's
yeah i think that's it and it works
because
i have no idea what goes on inside of
his head on a directing
and story and vision level and i would
never attempt to do that job i never
would insert myself into his shoes or or
want to do that or
try to do that and and similarly he
doesn't step on my toes so it's not it's
not like we're
converging at this one point where we're
both trying to do each other's
jobs so just works out
so writing a screenplay how much of it
do you think comes from you
and how much of it do you think comes
from some other source
muse up in the sky somewhere right you
know this is this is an interesting film
because
i think it's the first time i've ever
experienced this
and then you know we
i wrote the script and i worked on it
for a long time
and then we made the movie and i just
felt and i think it's maybe why
i i love it so much is because it just
feels like when the film came together
it just feels like it's something um
more than what i wrote you know um
to me you know i guess when i look at it
i see something
else going on in the film then
um that i put there and
um so that there is this other part of
when you just juxtapose
ideas and images in a film magical
things can kind of come out of that
um you know in people's minds
you know so when you're combining this
moment with this moment then it creates
this other
um kind of unexpected moment in people's
minds and i think that that's something
that's really
awesome about filmmaking is that there
is always that possibility
um but but as far as the actual writing
process
um yeah i would say that
i mean it's impossible to say how how
much other stuff is influencing you
there's no question
often you know when i look at the stuff
that we we do i can see the influences
after the fact
you know it's not while we're doing it
that i know the influences but
you know now i can look back at the
frame and say like oh yeah that's that's
kind of a little bit out of this movie
and it's a little bit out of this story
or it's a little bit out of
this experience that i either read about
or had
so it is i mean i think it all comes
from other places in some way it's just
how it comes together that makes
your vision unique i guess
what do you observe from him and even
from your own process like to where
some of these ideas he he always uh i
know that there's always
one to three movies rattling around in
there at any given time um
three marbles he has literally just
three points three
three ideas that's it breakfast
lunch that's for dinner no he's
uh he'll never he'll kind of
tell me in the early stages that he has
an idea but i know he's not going to
tell me until it's pretty well formed
and once it's well formed enough then
we'll kind of start talking about it um
and i can't say i
i don't think i ever necessarily
influence the ideas
but like on the on the frame for
instance i think it was just a lot more
aware
of providing feedback at critical times
like at this
at the scripture level before you have a
lot of resources and
people involved or um which really i
mean
i think we changed probably very little
after your original script
almost nothing really um or during the
edit just being more critical at points
during that of just if there's just a
certain moment that
i think could be better or needs to be
changed a little bit or something but
um it's it's all it's all him
it's all it's all between here and here
and
well that's something that i mean that
has been a big thing uh that's changed
between ink and
the frame is i would say that you know
over the years you've just gotten better
and better at giving me
um really good feedback and i mean the
script did change some i mean i think
that
um and and just in the post-production
process i just think that it's just
it's been really nice because kyo has
gotten
more and more i think film savvy over
the years and has just been able to give
to be
a really good sounding board for me just
to
um just to know something's working or
not so i hope so
yeah yeah what's the future of
filmmaking
and film distribution five ten fifteen
years from now
oh i don't know about five minutes from
now um
uh i really don't know i
um i feel like it's con it's kind of
two separate paths right now the
one to one million to thirty million
dollar movie is gone
um uh auteurs
or maybe getting final cut in that price
range
no longer um are getting any
um final cut or anything like that so
it's either turned into the
200 million dollar tent pole blockbuster
of which
you know that's just going to keep going
they're just going to keep rebooting the
same stories and keep putting those out
every summer
and or doing what we do which is very
low budget
you know under 500 movies even down to
the micro budget
world and um i think it's just going to
be a matter of
people kind of operating in that range
can you start to actually build your own
audience
that follows your own career and your
own work there is no i think
film festivals are dead in a sense of
there is no
premiering a movie at sundance and
becoming robert rodriguez or
tarantino anymore i think i think that
ship sailed long ago
film festivals are not about discovery
anymore they're about getting stars and
people
and out to their festivals and um
so our path is just we're just carving
out our own
thing and we hope that between ink and
now this
and our short films and jamin's first
feature 1159 that
that now kind of shows a body of work
and we're not stopping and
if if the snowball keeps rolling down
the hill
that will accumulate enough stuff
and we talk a lot about authenticity and
i think that's really the future i mean
i think
to your point i mean i think that yeah
the temple films are going to continue
and there's going to be bigger and
bigger films and fewer of them
but i think what is happening and what
will continue to happen over the next
five years
is that there's going to be more niche
audiences
so that if you know there's going to be
filmmakers making smaller films like
what we're doing
um and and even smaller there's some
great great films that are being made
for five ten thousand dollars
but they're much more niche oriented and
um they're finding their audiences
because they are so niche and i guess i
feel like that that's the future is that
um there's gonna be more voices which i
do think is a good thing and there's
gonna be a lot more freedom because
um there's not so much money going into
them but
then to the point of your first question
um
the the way in which to survive and how
to support
yourself while doing that that's that's
the tricky thing but i think there's
there's definitely going to be an
audience for all kinds of any films
just how to monetize that in a way that
um
that people can survive is the really
tricky part and um
but i think that that's i i don't i
think what we know is that we don't know
i mean i think what we know is that
the industry is changing rapidly and
that it's still the future is still
being defined every day
and just because it seems like oh it
doesn't feel like there's a really good
way to monetize it now
doesn't necessarily mean there's not
going to be and i think that that could
change overnight
um and i guess i feel like it will um
but we'll see we'll see if i'm wrong
it's on tape now so
yeah um well and then the goal from
there is i
i do think that it will
something will have everybody gets so
doomsday the sky is falling everything
is
burning to the ground um and i think
it's been a rough couple of years
there's no question
that things were we're getting off the
old system
nobody's quite figured out the new
system yet and nobody knows what that is
it'll happen i guess in that trough
period i hope that we're doing a smart
thing by just
continuing to keep full integrity of
what we're doing
and making exactly the movies we want to
make
and hoping that you know people find the
authenticity in that and then they find
that
you know james a director that they want
to follow and that we're
we are the snowball rolling down the
hill so that when that thing gets
figured out
we're going to be okay
how soon in the filmmaking process do
you start
selling the idea to your fan base and
you have a very
enthused fan base some are local some
are not and
how soon did you start leaking news
about the frame basically the casting
process i guess
with this we you know
we spent a long time trying to decide
what we were going to make
next and i was going between two
different scripts
and the frame was one of them and we
ultimately decided to go with the frame
so once the script was done with the
frame
we knew we were going to move forward on
production then we
i guess started a frame facebook page
and the very first thing we put out was
just a picture
of the front of the script and that was
a and that was
that was what six months before we
started it was almost exactly two years
ago
yeah yeah so um so yeah production was
last summer uh april to
late june 2013 and then it's been a year
of post-production we literally finished
the movie about two weeks ago
and we just waste no time we get
we get right onto the next thing but uh
um yeah we put news out
i guess in november of 2012.
we just took a pic we started a frame
facebook page posted that picture on our
ink facebook page you know the frame by
jamin weining is just a picture of the
script
and started to you know convert people
from our ink facebook page which you
know at least we have that
as a starting point to start getting
people interested in this movie and then
have continued to kind of post stuff
there and post stuff on the frame page
and
and i think that was and it's a little
bit tricky because i think with
the way that we have put out the you
don't want to wear people out
you know and it's such a long journey
from um
the script all the way through
post-production to premiering it you
have to be careful you don't completely
exhaust your fan base
um you know too much news and so i guess
we were
we were fairly sparse with the stuff
that we're putting out
initially and then during the shoot when
we had a lot of interesting pictures to
to put up we shared those with with the
fans
and um but it's just been it's been very
much
i think it's been a good process and
that it's just kind of kept people
on board with the journey the whole way
through and um
so those those fans that we we have now
um feel a little bit more part of
the experience and they kind of are more
part of the experience i mean it's kind
of the uh
it's i mean it really does make a
difference for us when we're getting
you know fans you know just constantly
giving us just positive support
all the time and it really does make a
difference i mean i think um
a lot of people look at um i mean
there's there are downsides to
social networking as well but i mean
generally it's been a really positive
thing because it's really
difficult to get through it's just nice
to be reminded like oh wait no there are
people that like what we're doing
like they support us and there is going
to be an audience for the film when it
comes out and that's
that's been a huge part of it so it's
just kind of helped us through through
the whole
journey how was your process when you
determined if something was too much
information or
if if it was the right time i mean i'll
see a lot of filmmakers they'll put out
oh
exciting news is coming guys hang on
hang on and then another
but but sometimes i think it's almost
better to just wait
hold it and then bam here it is here's
the exciting news what was your process
in deciding what you're going to put out
we we have a lot of discussions about
that because uh
we really only want to post stuff when
it's relevant we kind of went
largely off the grid after inc for a few
years and because we were fairly active
on twitter while we were promoting that
and
and there is a time where you just have
to live as well
and shut literally turn the button off
um
and so coming back and and starting to
kind of get the engines rolling for the
frame of get
again is it was a very conscious
decision to
only post things when they're relevant
and we've actually gotten
i think you just get better at not um
not letting the cat out of the bag too
early i'm just like okay well we're
gonna post our trailer on
in two weeks from now and so you know
we'll do like a three day lead up to
that but we're not going to start
talking about it now
and we're not going to tell people
trailer in you know three weeks or
something it's just
um and also we've gotten i think a lot
more
it's hard to ride the line of you know
of course people love more
maybe personal information or something
like that but
but we're a little more um
i don't know private i guess yeah we try
to
make sure that the the content is more
about
the films and less about us i guess um
and because and i think that's a choice
i mean some people um really put their
own personalities out there and
we tend to think that our films are more
interesting than we are so
we try to keep it focused on the films
and um
so yeah and just trying to um only put
out
like you said kind of stuff that we
think people are really going to be
interested and
interested in and stuff that feels more
relevant but it's a tricky thing because
you know with this film especially and
everything we do we try to keep things
very hush-hush so kind of
giving people something without giving
yeah without giving anything away
and yeah yeah we put out a trailer that
says nothing about the movie
right right but that's exactly the
trailer we wanted to make we're really
extreme on one side for sure
but um but yeah but i think for the most
part i think it's been
you know fairly successful and just on a
side note in in keeping things secretive
it it makes people even more curious
i hope you hope so i mean we've had
discussions about that too
just uh there was a reason why michael
jackson was the king of pop as he
showed up he danced his ass off and he
was amazing and then he just
disappeared yeah and we don't think
we're michael jackson but
um but uh
truly i mean i think that there's a
because of all the availability of all
these social networks oh my god we've
got to be on instagram and twitter and
this and
pinterest and all these things and
there's a little bit of mystery lost
that you know that mystique i think is
gone a little bit
from a lot of people's promotional
efforts
and um i think the movie lends itself
well to
remaining mysterious people after seeing
it four times
are still mystified that's right
i mean they're not but it's it
thematically works and it works for us
as people
um but i think that's something really
cool like
you love a band or a rock star because
you're they're just there and then
they're gone you know
i hope anyway but tonight you're
screening in l.a yeah
the q a will be here and will you stick
around afterward for
just sort of a meet and greet yeah okay
yeah absolutely yep
we'll be around we're also giving out
free um
11 by 17 posters so